Jiu Jitsu Kaizen has firmly established
itself as one of the biggest Shonen
Blockbusters of this generation I've
always said that it's done that on the
heels of groundbreaking fight animation
a very strong cast of characters that
feel relevant and character dynamics
that keep you surprised with every
twister gets pulled on us we've spent
the past Season watching highlights of
our main Trio and especially Gojo and
we've been blessed with insane battles
to remember the best part of it all
we're not even at the exciting part yet
Jujitsu kaizen's second season takes us
to the Shibuya Arc which for me is the
peak of the series as of the time of
this writing mistakes have never been
higher before and in between the great
fights and lots of moments that ought to
get us hyped and sad prepare yourself
for a whirlwind of emotions entering
this season and I'm not even sure all
that preparation is going to be enough I
can't wait for the Shibuya Arc and I'm
sure the Die Hard Jujutsu Kaizen fans
have it way worse than I do
[Music]